parce qu'elle est ce normal des vins de
cette félicité au mois de décembre
vivant on en a toute l'année à montréal
des vents forts je vous montrais tantôt
le tableau des vents les plus violents
observés à montréal savons répondre à
votre question mais pour vous est ce
qu'on a observé un aéroport 105 km alors
le son de sa voix le record de 103 on a
battu en mai le record était à 103 donc
on l'a battu par 2 kilomètres à l'heure
ont un bon pote beaucoup mais quand même
on l'a battue donc c'est un record qu'il
avait établi justement 11 décembre 1975
donc à 103 on l'a battue à 105 km à la
mais quand même on a affaire on a faim
on eu affaire à une tempête qui l'amène
j'ai relié au tournant exactement oui
mais ce ne sont pas des vents de la
tornade qu'on a eues ici et
d'échappement poser la question le nom
c'est le même système qui pourra voir
que ces tornades qui pourrait avoir ce
temps violent qui a porté la pluie
verglaçante la pluie les vents forts je
vous disais déjà depuis jeudi vous
rappeler jeudi je voudrais 90 et plus y
aura des pannes de courant on voyait
venir le monstre et comme on le voit si
cette tempête est extrêmement vaste et
elle recourt à peu près le tiers du
continent sont dignes d'un système très
puissant et c'est ce qu'on a observé et
ça ça se passe ça s'est passé vraiment à
l'arrière du système et c'est là qu'on
voit les vents les plus forts
fréquemment lorsque la pression se met à
monter extrêmement rapidement est ce que
va vous demander si vous êtes vous aviez
su travailler pour hydro-québec ce que
notre invité vous vous demanderez c est
ce que ça va se produire comme ça de
plus en plus sûres on sait qu'
effectivement le climat devient plus
extrêmes qui est plus probable qu'on ait
des vents violents selon nos calculs et
en 2019 le 1er novembre 2010 vent tout
aussi fort alors on voit qu'on a des
fréquences quand même devancé assez
puissant cela dit par rapport à ce qu'on
a observé dans le passé je vais vous
montrer les vents les plus violents
observés à montréal 5 mars 1964 161e qui
le mettra hors c'est quand même énorme 1
56 en février 138 le 2 juillet 1975 en
26 octobre 117 en 1979 et le 22 janvier
59,77 donc on voit vraiment que les
vents les plus violents
on s'est éparpillé dans la saison
effectivement mais la panne c'est pour
le mois de mars alors que de fortes
tempêtes qui passent donc certes il a
vanté très fort on en a vu quand même
des pires dans le passé donc ça c'est
clair puis à 105 on est vraiment
peut-être au septième art
mais normalement je finis avec ce pass
crime et parce que vous disiez il y en a
pas deux tornades de janvier aux états
unis vous êtes habitudes ou gammes
tactiques tempête là à créer des
tornades exceptionnel l'exception de
l'un effectivement sur internet de cette
puissance et de cette violence et qui
aussi meurtrière on a envoy extrêmement
rarement en décembre c'était d'une rare
type total pour ne pas dire totalement
impossible presque alors que l'on voit
des soldats de cette force là en me
c'est là qu'ont eue les tornades les
plus violents mais ses parts à 2015 on
avait un événement de tornades de noël
qui avait aussi puissant que ça mais
c'était sur le sens des états unis mais
c'était l'exception l'a vraiment un
autre registre on parle de quoi on est
en hausse à 74 mans si je ne m'abuse 114
114 morts et possiblement une puissance
de f5 avec des ventes 400 kilomètres à
l'heure c'est à dire quatre fois plus
fort que ce que vous avez vécu sur le
sud du québec samedi soir comme si il
vous disiez décembre n'existe plus
décembre n'est plus le décembre qu'on
devrait connaître normalement
climatologie on le voit par les
températures qu'on aura justement jeudi
avec un degré écoutez ce n'est plus le
même mois de décembre qu'on regarde dans
la climatologie dans le passé l'a très
bien merci beaucoup à tout à l'heure
pascal